powered big announcement so it's a
little after nine o'clock yes these
bookstores are open it's finally here
your book is available yes and to
celebrate you yes we're gonna present
something to you that you've always
asked for Howard man please introduce
the New York City Gospel Choir
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh this is unbelievable this is the New
York City Gospel Choir you can sing and
let me tell you something I was a judge
on America's Got Talent so I know
singing when I hear to my right Rob
that's right can't you get an amen I
always wanted to work with a choir wow
wow what an honor you know I always
wanted to try this with a choir I'm
moving on move to the east
I finally got a piece of the pie
[Music]
this is an exciting day my book is free
to express yourself first of all I want
to get an amen I would like to get a
hallelujah I would like to get an amen
for my hallelujah I would like that too
hallelujah amen can I get an amen for
Conan O'Brien who I declared my best
interview ever can I get a daisy and how
about the Holy Trinity Simon & Schuster
mr. Jonathan Karp and me can I get a
soft hallelujah look at this Oh I'm
directing I love it
about an Amen for some of the people in
the book like mr. Jerry Seinfeld
thank you very much and how about mr.
David Letterman ah man yes sir I mean
that man is a recluse grew a big white
beard like Santa Claus and then he
agreed to be interviewed and discussed
in my book isn't that something
for the first time in this choirs
history I would like to get an amen
backwards which is a mean Magni money
speaking in tongues I think
can I get a hallelujah burying an amen
right now go
that was horrible let's get an amen for
all the photographers who have taken my
picture on this promotional tour and who
haven't made me look like a monster i
want to say amen to the photographer
from hollywood reporter new york times
magazine
amy you turn my face just a little bit
and i can go from a 2 to a 0 very quick
robin
man what about a hallelujah / Fred can I
get a hallelujah the fact that I can
keep Fred's face hidden but after two
long years amen and hallelujah I have a
book I have a book and with that I say
thank you thank you and God bless the
New York City Gospel Choir true talents
and Marc Anthony thank you for coming in
here today and honoring me and now I say
take it away guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you get that up on the app
immediately I felt like Jesus